advertisers and the staff of
the simon's institute for
excellent workshop and smoothly running
and just great
hopefully that will induce them to turn
the light out of the board
sorry
it wasn't true okay
i have
i think i have uh 20 minutes and i
probably only have 30 or 40 new concepts
and problems today
so uh given all this excess time that i
have i
have the ability of time to tell you a
little story
and then story
is uh about how such a list of
co-authors could have
uh been assembled and what could have
happened
to have five co-authors on this this
work
amazing huh
they're all at the beginning of the
alphabet you know
my name i'm usually the last author but
yeah i could have even been there
so actually the story is uh
very connected with a bunch of our talks
here
steve smale i was a student here 1964 to
67 in dynamics
and uh
steve smell was had been a topologist
and he
turned the sphere inside out improved
the prime create conjecture and got the
fields medal
and shortly thereafter he changed
subjects he did this many times in his
life and he changed subjects to
dynamical systems and he
wrote a great paper
everybody should read in 1967 both the
american math society about differential
dynamical systems
and then a few years later he changed
subjects again
and he was studying economics
and uh he proved the theorem
the fundamental theorem of welfare
economics that there's a price system
that clears the market which was the
subject of the talk this more was it
this morning or yesterday i'm so low i'm
sure everybody's lost uh
so uh he proved this theorem and i
actually was at a conference once in
england so he's presenting his theorem
and his theorem was by what he called
the global newton method which was
actually you can now read
this proof in milner's topology from the
differentiable viewpoint book there's a
proof of the brow fixed point theorem in
there
that proof of the borrower fixed point
theorem can be turned into an algorithm
so that's smale and hersh turn that
proof into an algorithm which they
called global newton
and they proved that the solution curves
of global newton always converge to
uh an optimum
but here's this conference and at the
conference there's scarf he's got an
algorithm and there's uh harold kuhn
from princeton he's got an algorithm and
steve's got an algorithm and how you're
supposed to compare these algorithms
so now we have another change of subject
he becomes interested in
how you
judge complexity and efficiency of this
different disparate collection of
algorithms that are now numerical
algorithms
so steve being steve he picks a a very
definite a problem that's classical
oriented and of clear interest
and he says let's do this one and this
one doing this one will
tell us what the theory should be
and so what his problem was
the fundamental theorem of algebra given
the complex polynomial
you're supposed to find a root
and he writes a paper again in
1981 bowling american math society
called the fundamental theorem
of algebra
and uh at some point during that time
i visited berkeley and he asked me some
questions and i could help him and
give him some ideas and so i stayed
vaguely interested in following his work
there and when he wrote the paper
i realized
that the algorithm he has presented
and the analysis he did the upper bound
estimate was infinite average cost
so now he he had a hook he hooked me in
and we started working together so then
we found some finite average course
algorithms in one variable
and then jim renegar went and did n
variables and then we went and did end
variables and
now all these years later
here's peter and the problem is
made a lot of progress not yet quite
solving on smail's list 17th problem
and variables but there's kind of a
transition a natural transition
you know i used to work at uh
ibm
and i had the impression there
that uh it was a great a great great job
while it lasted
and
i had the impression there that if
anybody asked me a question i'd have
something to say about it
but this something might take me 20
years
which
wasn't quite their business model
but
but even so they were quite tolerant of
me and treated me well i had a very good
scientific life there
sometime in this
20-year period that i was actually there
we had focm in
rio
1997. and uh
i called up peter lax
and invited him to give a plenary talk
at the
rio meeting which he declined to do
but then we were sort of chatting about
things
and he said mike what have you been
working on recently i saw various things
in dynamics and
complexity theory about solving systems
of polynomial equations
and he said to me on the telephone he
said well if you were getting
eigenvalues of matrices that would
interest me
so here we are 20 years later and it's
like ibm and
in the meantime there's a little uh work
has progressed then we've we've gotten a
lot of uh
information about the polynomial problem
and now maybe it's time to return to the
eigenvalue problem which
have to ought to be
easier to analyze so then
diego montano came to see me in toronto
i was working in toronto time i wanted
to be my graduate
suggested that
john pierre and i
share him as a student and he worked on
this eigenvalue problem so then he
worked on the eigenvalue problem but
somehow
he didn't finish the job
like you do you can't force your student
to finish the job they've been there
enough time they have to go they have to
get a job
have children you know live a life
so uh he didn't quite finish the job and
so that was a couple of years later he
didn't quite finish the job show
so then we said okay we have to finish
this job and so carlos beltran and i
uh i was in
at the in buenos aires these years and
diego's in montefideo so he could come
across the river and
we spent some time together so okay
we're gonna finish the job here
and felipe and peter independently uh in
berlin so that they were gonna finish
the job and unbeknownst to
each other we're both finishing
this job
so now there are two papers on the
archive
which are about to be merged into one
which will be i hope better than either
one of them which will resolve this
through some theory yeah just to add
that we actually knew
that
each other we were doing the same job
thanks to this workshop yeah we only
learned here it wasn't the abstract oh
yeah right we didn't know we didn't know
even when we were here peter was down
the hall and i was over there we didn't
know that
anyway so now we know and so there's now
five people involved and
a job that should have been finished by
our graduate student
some years back
and the the whole subject is exactly
what peter
described
to today i don't have to
so he eigenvalue problem is i'm going to
take
a matrix
n by n complex
general m by n complex matrix
uh where
you put a uh
gaussian on the on each independent
identically distributed
gaussians on all the entries of this
matrix
and now you ask to find uh
lambda and v
such that a of v
minus lambda of v equals zero
so that's
that's the problem
and the solution that we propose is you
start with one let you know maybe let's
find all the eigenvalues so
so find them all
let me just discuss that that case for
the while
all
n end of them
that's actually
this problem
in my mind is a bilinear problem it's
not a quadratic problem so to make it
bilinear a and lambda come together and
v comes separately
and then the bilinear
bazoo theorem gives you n as the number
of roots
if you were to treat this as a quadratic
system you would be predicting
two to the n roots and in fact infinity
would be
a root all of infinity would be a root
of the problem
and it would be all degenerate since we
don't want to deal with degenerate
systems
we think about it as by as bilinear
okay and the and the solution of the
problem is you take
a zero with some lambda zero i and v
zero i and then you take an a1 you want
to solve and you write down the
homotopic
t equals and we'll take the straight
line homotopia
just for convenience sake in fact it's
not truly not the best one so we take
that straight line homotopy a uh t
equals
uh 1 minus t times a0
plus t times a1
and we continue the root
so the theorem is uh
approximate zero's approximate
eigenvalue
eigenvector pairs
are found
with probability one
these approximate are in the sense of
smale that newton's method is going
to converge
approximately
i found with a with
probability
one
and the cost and the average cost
is polynomial in
sorry i gotta ask a stupid question i
can't hear you speak louder i said i'm
sorry i have to ask a stupid question
but what's wrong with gaussian
elimination for eigenvalues you find
roots that way but not values
you find z you find the solution a
gaussian elimination is to find a x
equals b
here we want to find the eigenvalues
you can compute the roots of a
characteristic
yeah no no i'm going to say a few things
yeah okay
that's one of the galaxy eliminations to
find the characters
yeah yeah
okay so let me say several things first
thing is
most likely
these continuation algorithms are not
most likely are not competitive with
what numerical linear algebra people do
they have algorithms that work great in
practice
uh let me mention a few of them one
might be qr
qr algorithm
i can tell you what you take your matrix
m and you write it as qr and you write m
as rq and then you iterate
and this matrix is supposed to converge
to one that's uh upper triangular and
you read the eigenvalues down the
diagonal
that's qr then you might have qr with
shifts
maybe one was the rayleigh quotient
shift
i could tell you a story about that one
too
but
maybe i am getting short in time third
one is uh
a qr
with francis shift
and then a fourth one characters compute
the characteristic polynomial
solve it
so let me point out that this one for
example
is an algorithm for the eigenvalues but
not the eigenvalue eigenvector pair
so
that may cause a problem and i'll speak
about that
in a minute uh
so
several things this algorithm here
i would bet dollars to donuts that used
to be that used to be
a good bet from the taker's point of
view maybe a dollar maybe don't of
course more than a dollar these days
i would bet dollars to donuts
that
this algorithm is infinite average cost
it converges almost always but i would
bet it's infinite average cost
so this is
the problem that a lot of these
algorithms will fail
probably on some kind of surface of
co-dimension one or a divider or
something
they'll fail and the cost will go to
infinity as you approach
this thing the question is
what does that pole look like
when you integrate you're going to have
a poll but is it going to be finite or
is it going to be infinite it's a
delicate analysis
so i i would bet this one
is infinite average
nothing's proven about it that would be
a good project for some student
this one
fails for an open set of real matrices
so that
so it certainly is for the real matrices
is infinite average cost
so this is in general matrices but the
matrices are symmetric
these algorithms are great
this algorithm it converges all the time
and does it rapidly but there's no
complexity analysis
this one converges almost all the time
but i think it's an infinite average
course this one fails on open sets of
real matrices it's unknown for complex
matrices does it work for complex
matrices with probability one or not
unknown as far as i know
this one also unknown this is a favorite
one
and uh there's a very nice article by
batterson which will just discusses this
algorithm from a dynamics point of view
his audit
proves that in fact wilkinson proved
and then parlet proved for symmetric
matrices that
uh these algorithm
uh works
all the time
but for non-symmetric matrices it fails
here he proves for normal matrices it
works almost all the time very few
exceptions this one
that's an interesting one
trefethan's book so you have wonder what
did the miracle linear algebra people do
chauffethan says in his book on
numerical linear algebra never compute
the characteristic power
it's never computed he says it is not
backwards stable and then they always
give this example
of the
wilkinson polynomial which is x minus 1
times x minus 2 up to x minus 20.
and
if you look at that as a matrix it's 1
it's completely stable as a matrix for
the eigenvalue eigenvector problem even
but as a polynomial when you write it
out if you change the middle co some
middle coefficient by 10 to the minus
15th or something
the eigenvalues become complex all over
the plane and it's just a mess
so they say don't do it uh that it's not
it doesn't give you the right answer
so actually i think that's a very
interesting question to explain this
from the point of view of condition of
the problem as a matrix problem as
condition of the problem as a polynomial
problem
for example you i have to define what
the condition of the matrix is let me do
that now
so the condition of the matrix
for the eigenvalue problem so a lambda v
where it's a where
where uh
a
of v equals lambda v
then the condition number of this
point on the solution variety
is mu
of a lambda and v
is equal to
the norm of the matrix project on v perp
of lambda i
minus a
restricted to v perp
this is the hermitian complement of v
inverse
this is uh
the condition number
of the polynomial you might wonder
we already had a condition number for
polynomials
how this condition number compares to
the condition number for the for the
polynomial
do you want to multiply it with the
normal phase
yes thank you
how does this condition number
compare
to the condition number of the
polynomial
uh in fact so many of the matrices will
be well conditioned
some of them like the companion matrix
of the polynomial itself will be as
badly conditioned as the polynomial
i i guess one would want to know what is
like the average of the condition number
in the fiber
i suppose the average will be a lot less
so that the
eigenvalue problem with the given pollen
characteristic polynomial will be much
more likely to be solved well by matrix
techniques
than uh
reduction to the characteristic
polynomial
and solving that does that
address your question
okay so what what about this this is uh
a hey in a haystack problem we're not
quite
so now that once you've made all these
definitions
you just do what peter did and it's
talking you have to
thank you
that's it you just so there's nothing
more for me to say the theorems on the
board and the technique is as it was
except for uh a a few more comments
maybe
so uh let me see what what did i want
i made myself a list what do i put in my
pocket
how did i
uh
linear algebra the straight line by the
way the straight line homotopies are
probably oh there's another one what is
the newton's method and what is the
update
so
i uh see i have six or seven minutes
maybe that's the most important thing i
can say i might ask we might ask what
are
the best condition
matrices from the point of view of
summing
this condition number squared over
the different
suppose i sum this
over the eigenvalue eigenvector pairs
this is a function defined on the
space of matrices what's the smallest
value
so it's at least
n times the square root of two
and i think we proved that the average
on the unit sphere
average
on the unit sphere in mnn
is something like less than or equal to
n cubed
so
it's easy
to find uh
examples that are close to the mean
as it whereas in polynomial systems
that's a wide open problem so
peter gave you
an estimate of what the average
condition number is and then he gave you
an example which is much much worse than
the average
and we don't know how to find
one
even in one variable we don't know how
to find
good points
but our polynomial in the average
here in the eigenvalue problem
it's easy you pick any old one
so you make up a put the eigenvalues out
on the plane this is not a hard problem
to get close to the mean
but what is the best it might be a lot
better
than this n cubed because the lower
bound that i only that i know is and
square root of two
so that's uh that's one good open
problem and the second thing i just
wanted to
explain is something that uh
that these algorithms of course the
estimates we do
are upper bound estimates
and so the algorithms that we exactly
prescribe are very very careful
algorithms where we can keep track of
everything that's happening
practitioners wouldn't do that and
part of the problem what we did
is back goes back to what steve smell
and i did is what newton's method we
picked
so we actually picked the newton's
method
that is not good from the perspective of
implementation
so let me just say what the difference
is so in case anybody actually ever
looks at the algorithms we write down
they will see what not to do
and how to change it
so the
approach
so suppose you have uh
some parameter space like this and you
have your solution curve
maybe like that
now uh
what steve and i did we said okay here's
a parameter value and let's just make
believe believer actually on the curve
or close to the curve right over here
now he said okay let's increment this
and how much can we increment it we'll
have to
well we have some method of telling you
and peter and
felipe have some method of telling you
how much to
increment t to t plus delta t
and then what we say is we take this
value itself
and we use that for newton's method at
this
new point
so we simply take the same value
now a much better implementation would
be to take the tangent vector to this
curve which is anyway the newton
direction you're already computing it
so you take this tangent vector and move
in the direction of the tangent vector
and use this point
as your new starting point for newton's
method you're surely going to be closer
to the curve
why didn't we do that
we didn't do that because this involves
two computations
and
in the estimates that we were doing you
had to compute this and then you had to
compute another
inverse of the derivative at a new point
so you had to do that twice
and we didn't see that we got enough
gain in the step that we could that we
could guarantee
justify the extra algebraic cost
so we only analyze this algorithm
and
certainly in practice
that's not the right thing to do
the right thing to do is maybe look at
this whole line
do some kind of a search like they do in
numerical methods you may be double your
step size if it's working well or half
it if it's very difficult
not to take a prescribed step but to use
the tangent to the curve and take a long
step
so included in such a strategy is yet
one more open problem
and that is what's the average curvature
of these curves
and the solution variety
so for quadratic programming or linear
programming we saw the average curvature
of the solution curves was small and
that could
explain a long step method that would be
much more
efficient than any of the bounds so
that's the last problem what's the
average curvature of the solution curve
five average
temperature
maybe one can say something about that
that would show that long step methods
would perform much better in practice
thank you
thank you for the nice readers in the
story
any question
i just want to make sure that i
understood that this eqr algorithm has a
guarantee for this metric
the qr algorithm for general matrices
will converge
uh to a
when the
modulus of the
eigenvalues are distinct for the moduli
but i'm asking about the symmetric case
this medication
is
i don't think qr in the symmetric case
will do any better
these things with shifts
the shifts are the fast ones
uh and the fast ones work in the
symmetric case it's a theorem so the
almost every symmetric matrices
you put them in uh
tri-diagonal form you do what you're
supposed to do and they
they converge
in fact every point converges either to
an eigenvector or to an angle bisector
of two eigenvectors
the the the method is
great
for symmetric matrices but there's no
complexity analysis done of it that i
know so
no complexity yeah
other questions
okay then we talk here
thank you again